all right so um Bill Cosby let's talk
about Bill Cosby because I've talked
about him yes before I think I was when
the first one to make jokes I never felt
bad about it because I was not divided
like my comics were who always were fans
I never thought he was funny I've said
that before so it wasn't like oh gosh
he's such a great artist but he turns
out to be this rapist first of all what
is your answer to people who say well he
deserves his day in court well I think
he's very lucky that the statute of
limitations is like six years in most
states in California it is so I think
he's a or that they are just allegations
well yes you can say that but you know
he's free I mean the country hasn't
thrown him in jail so but if he's free
we're allowed to say when 40 people
yeah of something that is a pretty good
chance that it happened that's the
difference people have to understand
size matters yeah nope seriously it does
I mean you hear yes I'm very very wary I
never used to do Michael Jackson has
such a little boy joke yes because I
don't know if that's true I mean over
the years it became a little more
apparent it might be uh but you know you
hear all Tom Cruise is gay I've seen
people make that joke on shows I don't
think Tom I don't know nobody knows but
I don't think he is who cares it's just
that's a real just out of my ass
allegation but forty women many with no
reason to be doing this is no money
that's coming to them they're not
looking for fame because some of them
Ernie have it's not fun to go on CNN at
sixty-five or seven years old rice say
that Bill Cosby raped you in the private
is I mean there's no reason to do it
and people have to remember that eighty
percent of rape victims never reported
to the police and eighty percent of rape
victims are raped by somebody they know
so so you got into this just because
you're outraged well I'm outraged by I
actually know one of the victims who's
not coming forward
and she said this is exactly what
happened and I think there's probably a
lot of people who are like I don't want
to go on TV I don't make this what I'm
about as a person I met a girl met a
girl I did a movie with somebody in 1983
who had just come off a movie with
little Cosby and had a horrific story
it's like I never meet anybody of the
male persuasion who doesn't have a story
about deli Osby this guy has put more
people to sleep than warm milk why the
question is you know you know I think
there's a larger issue which is why is
there so little outrage and I think it's
the same as you know old age why you
wrote a book about him you'd give us
that answer well 10 years ago I did and
what was equally appropriate to me was
the kind of assaults upon poor black
people poor black women especially all
the stuff he said you're gonna have to
have a DNA DNA cart in the ghetto pretty
soon to determine if you're making love
to your grandmother
because you have a baby at 16 the baby
has a baby when it's 16 he says you do
the math you could be making love to
your grandma that's that's pretty
nefarious that's pretty problematic but
nobody cared about it nobody paid
attention to it and I knew I had heard
some of those stories I talked about
them to a degree so my point is that
that if we're going to find a fence with
what he said there's so much arena there
so much area so much real estate to talk
about a bunch of stuff including that
but Woody Allen have to be thrown in
there and Roman Polanski as well no no
you don't think so
a patsy this is just a mass head it's
not 40 people it's one well I know well
I 20 Alan it's one accuser who had every
reason to hate him you mean yeah right
well but you know Ronan Lansky
definitely that's right I agree I have
no quarter for Roman Polanski or Ted
Kennedy you know there's certain things
you can't do can't drive into a river
and not report it for 10 hours and
summon drowns and you can't have sex
with a girl in the naughty place after
you drugged her right amen what I mean
amen amen but what do you come on I mean
that's the difference we're talking
about you're exactly right that when
these allegations come forward it is
tough to do this balancing act with due
process
and in the media and talk about the
allegation think you're exactly right we
have to do that the 40 women at this
point gets to the the point that we
think is right I do think the outrage
question about why there's not much of
outrage there was for a short time as I
write my book in the discussion the
cycle is very good that's right the
outrage cycle is super short and a lot
of times something that we really truly
should be outraged about is hoisted off
of the news cycle because of something
that we really shouldn't I think a lot
of it but I think about it is like how
funny they are you know people don't
want to believe it about Woody Allen
because then you can enjoy Woody Allen
movies so they instantly don't believe
his daughter no people think Bill Cosby
so funny that it takes 40 accusations
before we begin to think it's possible I
mean if this was me I'd be screwed at
two allegations you and you god you're
like it at 17 to 19 allegations it's
free your last appearance on such a
goodbye but I before a week